a las vegas family is mourning the death
of one of their own flavio sanchez
recently lost his fight
against covid and now his family is
speaking out christian kazaar is joining
us
in studio with their story and the
message they want you to hear
that's right brian well flavio sanchez
was a hard worker and a man of faith but
his biggest role was being a husband and
a father to his family
a love he held on until his final days
kind of breathed his fever was high
and they couldn't handle it no more
angel sanchez can't seem to forget the
last time he saw his father flavio
the 17 year old and his mother had to
rush him to the hospital
on january 6 after contracting covet 19.
unable to hold back her tears josefina
sanchez tells us flavio was the only
provider for their north las vegas
family
which includes four children she blames
those who don't follow the health
guidelines
for the death of her husband flavio
worked as a chef at a restaurant inside
mccarran airport
and when the pandemic hit his family
says he always watched over them
he would run errands on the bus and pick
up groceries by himself
according to his wife because he didn't
want them to be exposed
they believe that's where he may have
caught the virus the 52 year old mexican
father developed symptoms at the end of
december
and the virus quickly spread to most of
the family they all recovered
but flavio's death was deteriorating for
now the eldest son hopes to graduate
high school and quickly find a job to
help with the bills
while his mother also looks for work he
has this message to share
i gotta start wearing a mask like in
public or anywhere they go
like to not take it off even if it's at
a restaurant
or with family members just to keep on a
mask
well a gofundme account has been created
the sanchez family tells me they have
been able to re
to recover well to get uh money for rent
and bills
for the month of january but because
flavio was able to help secure some
covet relief funds
while he was hospitalized but that money
is quickly running out christian casadas
8 news now